la madonna un attimo buongiorno se uso
un gioco friendly ferri friendly questo
inchiostro devo cercare di passare
nascosto tra le tra l'algoritmo di
youtube se non mi bloccano il video la
che è successo e che è di questo
l'algoritmo siamo su rischia la card all
ok quindi io l'ho italianizzato carlo
abbiamo messo nel titolo carlo perché di
questo si tratta non so come fai a fare
un gelosi chiamarlo carlo però la bce
sta stanza c'è da basca mi spiego stato
lo fa il simbolo della porta
mi sono una sana e l'armadio ti ci puoi
nascondere però qual è il problema
ma senza il simbolo non si apriva la
porta scusami per come stavano
mi caso ma che il mona che fàcasino ii v
st vacca cosa è successo a posto non lo
so non me l'aspettavo mai c'erano
capitato non mi ha neanche visto che
sono entrato va dentro
eh eh ma è che sto casi chi che hai
fatto giusto bordello capiamoci c'è uno
nudo qualcuno non è nudo graziati va
perciò lascia che grossa come a matranga
deve rocco siffredi famme capì allora è
normale che sia per tosta porta è
cascato nudo chiudi la porta a posto non
mi hai visto entrare non mi hai mica
visto entrare dove sarà andato e bo mago
raul cremona prove poi non entrare nelle
mie porte grazie salve bel ciapet
comunque veramente family friends il tuo
gioco c'è un altro zio qua il suo amico
questo
non ho capito però fa niente pd non ho
capito il senso di piuttosto gioco c'è
veramente fino adesso non ha un senso ci
sono le boe vabbè coi giornali poi per
non far entrare la luce non ho capito il
senso ma non fa niente
no no no no no no no non è capito noi
capita non hai capito via via via via
che la porta a chiave la porta in faccia
bravo madonna queste chiusa c1 una
chiave diversa devo darli sotto odio e
tipo granny a livello di conformazione
del posto ma se un armadietto all'altro
cosa che mi piace un sacco fare come a
scuola ma smettiamo di ridere per
cortesia no va bene non ci credo cioè
sono uscito quando è sceso incredibile
se ci trovo milioni di volte non ci
riesco comunque l'obiettivo del gioco
penso sia uscire nel mentre che trovi
tutte le chiavi le chiavi hanno una
forma strana tipo con la cia la forma di
una luna nera
siamo qua fissa quarantena nel mentre io
sto registi hanno costruito in
quarantena tutto a posto
no non è tutto a posto continuano qua
siamo qua fermi a no penso che se si
segue
che male mi ha fatto c'è la lavatrice
globali sono rotto le palle non puoi
andare da casa tua che poi sta la
matrice ragazzi in motion che è
veramente non c'è i tasti cioè brivido
da poi mettere anno qua sono i tasti
bellissimo ben fatto bene start stop che
ha fatto bene il suo gioco sperli sono
anche lì così per le istruzioni
l'attrice mio dio
non riesco a capire perché sui giornali
ci sia sta roba però
ma che cosa ci fate e si è messo a
squartare il quale il tuo problema c'era
un riscatto piccola il suo problema
madonna nipote di un ostello sulle sedie
vi prendeva salve mi scusi non volevo fa
niente due sono le tue 46mila no non è
l'orario quello è il minutaggio del
video la videocassetta sony ci avevo
chiuso televisore ci avevi anche tu
grande basta ridere che fastidio
dio mio no no no no no no no no no no ok
ok
porca vacca che palle però mi chiamano
può esser entra in una bomba dai dai
file serio fi qualcos'altro mi ha fatto
malissimo mi ha colpito come recupero la
vita con lui esattamente sempre dove
sono io
qui è sempre dove sono io se io sono in
cucina non in cucina se io sono in sala
luisa né che lui e da una parte o da
un'altra di programmi no lui è sempre
dove sono io ok poi ride e vabbè tanto
non ha senso non mi ha colpito non so
perchè ma mi sono chiuso la porta dietro
teoricamente non mi dovrebbe beccare
continua t2000 porta dietro
allora devo trovare altre chiavi in
tutto questo però non ho capito dove
dovrei trovarle c'è in giro immagini
fuggire si ma adobe kazan tale giorno
non avevo dubbi io sono in cucina tu sei
in cucina chiuda porta per una sfondato
di club di un sesto a trovare una
qualsiasi altra chiave ci sarà un'altra
chiave chiude qua dove lavoravi che si
così potrebbe far recuperare un po la
vita
teoricamente se sfonda la porta sono
morto era quello che stavo per dire ed è
successo e ancora prima che lo dici
dicessi così che tra parla non solo
ragazzi non c'entra niente ma io non ci
credo raga non ho trovato un'altra
neanche una
sono 65 porte non ho trovato più neanche
una chiave cioè impossibile sono
introvabili
c'è la videocassetta st porta ovviamente
chiusa ragazzi non so dove trovare le
altre chiavi non ne ho la più pallida
idea proprio non lo so diamo ancora più
di sotto e promette bene dal sangue
promette bene giorno l allegro almeno
allegro grazie a dio con i 18 trapano
usa questo ho trovato la chiave a
quadrato salve è che fa che il rumore li
sentite tutto agosto zio ben e
importante quello allora voi che vedo
che fate yoga molto stile sporco demonio
porco corri corri chi una volta bello di
tipo chiede a porta dietro non trovare
la chiave della porta a quadrato di
nuovo mentre tra parlano eccola non
scherzavo
e quella di trapani anche se devo
trovare la porta ma al quadrato porco
demonio dove non equa la troverò mai
ragazzi un altro mai ve lo dico io
eccola aperta una chiave questa è la
porta con la luna e l'altra perfetto qua
dentro sempre tutto allegro meno male
che recupera un po di vita dovrei
tornare alla porta iniziale perché la
parte iniziale c'era un po di vita
nell'armadio anche voi non prendi niente
aprì lo sportello e si recupera la vita
hai voglia di trapanare anche un po tua
madre
non so chi è do qualcosa ma non posso
più recuperare vita va bene è importante
questo però non farmelo non dirmelo con
un sound effect così brutto parco
demonio comunque sono arrivato alla
porta della luna è in uscita ma solo
bravissimo bastato il migliore sono
riuscito così ma no dai è veramente è
già finito
ma no ma no volevo durasse tantissimo ma
no mi chiami sempre l'utente era mai
fatto benissimo sul corto ma no che per
casa la facevano a skydrive a chiamare
frega
la sfida andai tanto ormai so tutto no
mi dispiace vissuto l'asse di più
cavolo vero preso bene aver high speed
run che fotte sega vai vai vai le sdo
non mi con anche fido deve andare o che
di qua sfidano ha fatto in non lo so
batterà il record mondiale ormai so dove
devo andare
qua si aprirà la porta ok ma ndo ritorno
al di sopra
sono bravissimo nelle sfide una ragazza
produttori giochi horror ci sto provando
no perché mi dispiace volevo che durasse
molto di più
dov'è la porta di sopra mi ricordo più
porco demonio dove sono le scale
eccole ok porto quadrata porta quadrata
porta quadrata porta quadrata porta
quadrata portava data proprio guarda
porta cordata porta quadrata ecco la
chiave e vado di software aperta no
veramente ragazzi quella sfida ne fa
citato non l'ho neanche visto em all
oggetto sapevo schivato bravo
oddio mi sto impegnando un sacco eccoci
ce la fa in un minuto quanto hanno fatto
hai messo il timer giampiero però capire
poi in quanto tempo l'ho fatta una
seconda volta
più di così penso sia impossibile poi
sono stato molto bravo peccato
conte durata la registrazione totale
otto minuti e 59 ok allora io vi
racconterò un po della mia vita adesso
quando ero piccolo giocavo a un sacco di
di giochi in generale proprio non solo
horror giochi tipo sulla play 1 poi la
play 2 poi mi si è rotta la play 2 ha
comprato un altra prey 2 per i 3 e gli
facevo tutti quanti in questa cameretta
che vedete siamo la play che stava là la
in quel punto lì in questo punto un po
più a sinistra e non si vede
all'inquadratura veramente figo
pian piano pian piano ho iniziato a
prenderla prossima la passione per i
videogiochi questa passione e poi
diventata e il mio futuro anche
lavorativo che youtube quello che state
vedendo è sempre nella stessa cameretta
si genera la stessa poesia videoludica
di quando ero bambino e questo signori
penso sia la cosa più più bella che una
persona poi è finito il tempo ciao
[Musica]